he forged his own path through a
political career spanning five decades
mayor of Paris Prime Minister twice and
president for 12 years
Jacques Chirac held almost all the top
jobs he was one of the most prominent
politicians in post-war France Chirac
was born in Paris in 1932 after
receiving a privileged education his
political prowess was clearly evident
he spent the 1950s working in the civil
service
before becoming a protege of Prime
Minister George Pompidou after that his
climb was steep and fast within 12 years
he was Prime Minister a role where he
would push for welfare reform his march
to the Elysee Palace began after he left
the cabinet's becoming mayor of Paris in
1977 where he set his eyes on the
presidency it would be almost 20 years
before he would gain his seat in the
Elysee say he was elected promising tax
cuts and more jobs but within months
there was a general strike bringing
millions onto the streets during his
time in office he championed the single
currency but the budget the Elysees
sword
in 2003 the US President George Bush
failed to persuade Shearer act to join
the invasion of Iraq winning the French
leader praise from some quarters two
years later
Chirac failed to persuade his own people
to vote for a new European Constitution
memories of his leadership will be
sullied by the corruption during his 18
years as Paris mayor in 2011 he was
convicted of embezzlement Jacques Chirac
though was a consummate French
politician a survivor but his legacy is
uncertain and damaged by his personal
failures